Did you know that Korea has the world's oldest international adoption program?
Other encouraging news is that in recent years,...
...the number of adopted children within the country has also been increasing.
So the statistics are showing that more and more people...
...are slowly but surely starting to realize the seriousness of adoption,...
...and are taking action nationwide and worldwide.
The other day, I went to visit an exhibition of photographs...
...where many Korean celebrities have taken part in a series of charity photo shoots.
The stars posed for pictures with orphans to help them find new parents.
It was very heartwarming!
I heard that nearly 10,000 babies are orphaned in Korea every year with no parents.
But another hopeful sign is that, with the help of others,...
...one third of them are adopted and find new homes.
I heard some news about that too.
The exhibition will hopefully raise people's concern for orphans...
...and encourage them to help homeless children find homes and families...
...and to eventually lead normal lives.
Even by just looking at a photo of Angelina Jolie with her adopted kids...
...don't you think that something like that encourages people...
...and raises awareness about adoption?
Despite all of the publicity and rumors,...
...I think that Angelina is very nice and brave...
...because she adopted children from developing countries.